[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend die energiekosten benzin gas
strom steigen und schreien allmählich
zum himmel wir sind schon wieder beim
allzeithoch und die bewegung nach oben
ist nach wie vor dynamisch
durchschnittsverbraucher merken das
sofort an der zapfsäule oder beim
nachtanken von heizöl und die anderen
kriegen die rechnungen etwas später
serviert und die stimmung wird dann die
gleiche sein man muss wissen dass ein
gerüttelt maß davon politisch gewollt
ist wenn ein co2 preis den klimaschutz
über den geldbeutel regeln soll dann
müssen die preise steigen das spürt
schon jetzt die industrie und nicht
jedes unternehmen hat die chance von
heute auf morgen klimaschonend zu
produzieren nils moni berichtet
düngemittel eines der produkte die im
stickstoff werk piesteritz produziert
werden mit der hilfe von erdgas durch
die aktuell hohen preise sieht sich das
unternehmen aber gezwungen die
produktion zu reduzieren um satte 20
prozent die situation ist tatsächlich
noch gar nicht da gewesen sowohl von der
explosion des gaspreises als auch unsere
unser schritt darauf zu reagieren die
produktion zu reduzieren wenn sich der
gaspreis nicht
kurzfristig verringert dann werden wir
auch weiter reagieren müssen die
produktion weiter reduzieren bis hin zu
einem stopp von produktionsanlagen als
resultat hat sich der preis von
düngemittel mehr als verdoppelt
landwirte stehen unter druck
das macht uns angst der handel sagt es
ist nicht sicher ob nächstes frühjahr
überhaupt ausreichend dünner für jeden
betrieb zur verfügung steht dh betriebe
suchen derzeit händeringend
möglichkeiten sich mit dünger
einzudecken zu diesen astronomischen
preisen eine kettenreaktion ausgelöst
durch den aktuell enorm hohen
erdgaspreis verbraucher sind auch direkt
betroffen fast die hälfte der haushalte
in deutschland heizt mit gas die
beratungsnachfrage steigt in der tat
über hunt das ist auch kein wunder viele
verbraucher sind verunsichert es werden
ja gast preise kommuniziert oder gast
preisanstiege kommuniziert von bis zu
zwölf prozent eine ganze reihe von
faktoren soll für den anstieg des
gaspreises verantwortlich sein wie der
steigende co2 preis das wiederanfahren
der wirtschaft nach dem ende von corona
beschränkungen sowie erhöhter bedarf aus
asien und südamerika
die steigende nachfrage treibt den preis
bei ohnehin begrenztem angebot
dass es strukturell durchaus knapp weil
zum beispiel in europa selber das
angebot in den letzten jahren deutlich
gesunken ist beste beispiel ist die
produktion ihren geht die produktion
praktisch komplett zu ende und wenn man
die anderen europa durch gestalten wir
die produktion geht auch noch im
niedersächsischen rehden ist einer der
größten erdgasspeicher europas mit knapp
einem fünftel der deutschen
speicherkapazitäten zurzeit ist denn nur
zur fünf prozent gefüllt weit unter dem
bundesweiten durchschnitt
betreiber des speichers ist die
russische firma gazprom immer wieder
steht russland in der kritik die
lieferungen knapp zu halten damit nord
stream zwei schnell in betrieb genommen
wird russland aber weist diese vorwürfe
zurück
red bull sind sogar bereit mehr gas zu
liefern aber wir brauchen anfragen ich
sage ihnen wir liefern so viel wie
nachgefragt wird die eu-kommission
präsentierte jetzt maßnahmen die es den
einzelnen mitgliedstaaten ermöglichen
sollen kleine unternehmen und haushalte
mit niedrigen einkommen zu entlasten
auszahlung der eu aus dem
emissionshandel wären dieses jahr hoch
ausgefallen und könnten verwendet werden
um die bevölkerung zu schützen
frankreich und italien haben bereits
entsprechende steuersenkungen und
direktzahlungen angekündigt die
bundesregierung bisher nicht
und ausgerechnet in dieser lage passiert
heute etwas überraschendes führende
leute der industrie plus viel beachtete
wissenschaftliche beratergremium der
bundesregierung plus wirtschaftsberater
der industrie rufen nach berlin zu einer
gemeinsamen großen pressekonferenz und
verlangen von der zukünftigen
bundesregierung
entschlosseneres schnelleres
umfassenderes handeln im klimaschutz und
streckenweise klang das schon nach koste
es was es wolle
was sie aber vor allem fordern ist eine
gerade linie und klare ansagen das gab
es nach ihrer erfahrung offenbar bisher
nicht britta spiekermann berichtet es
sind überaus gewichtige argumente die
wirtschaftswissenschaftler und zwei
wissenschaftlerinnen in den händen
tragen jetzt sei keine zeit für klein
klein vielmehr die zeit überfällig für
eine radikale wende in der klimapolitik
bei der digitalisierung
es geht um große worte es geht um die
transformation von wirtschaft und staat
wissenschaft und unternehmen appellieren
an eine mögliche rot grün gelbe
regierungskoalition aus ihrer sicht
konkrete machtoption mit überzeugendem
reiz ich denke dass die ambitionen im
klimaschutz der grünen gut kombinierbar
sind mit den konzepten die die fdp
vorgeschlagen hat insofern halte ich so
eine dreier konstellation für sehr gut
geeignet und da mal ein wechsel in der
regierungskonstellation ist sicherlich
auch die möglichkeit einen solchen
neuanfang zu machen und zu kommunizieren
das muss ein projekt sein der
bundesregierung insgesamt klima und
umweltpolitik kann nicht mehr nur aus
dem umweltministerium heraus
vorangebracht werden deswegen muss
natürlich der klimaschutz in verbindung
mit der digitalen transformation
chefsache werden wenn jeder so seine
ponyhof hat und die einen dürfen
bisschen klimapolitik machen und die
anderen machen bisschen digitalisierungs
politik dann kriegen wir das nicht hin
die wissenschaft einer noch sondieren
den ampel hausaufgaben die am besten
schon gestern erledigt worden wären
nachhaltiges wirtschaften
klimaneutralität digitalisierung das war
zu beginn der regierungszeit von angela
merkel schon auf der agenda das heißt
eigentlich es braucht extrem viel
politisches kapital um dieses brett zu
bohren es geht um zentrale
vernachlässigte aufgaben es sind
seitenhiebe auf die noch amtierende bald
scheidende regierung wir haben diesen
gleichklang von aktivitäten zwischen den
ressorts in die beiden richtungen über
die wir heute sprechen klimaneutralität
und digitalisierung den haben wir nicht
gesehen deutschland braucht radikale
veränderungen nach jahren wo wir
vielleicht auch ein bisschen gemütlich
waren in teilen so modernisierung angeht
klimaneutralität sei die neue starb
saison der gesellschaftliche konsens
groß erreiche vom bundesverband der
deutschen industrie hin zu frei days for
future und dann wird es philosophisch
ist wie ich mal ganz starken satz machen
der hat gesagt die veränderung der
denkungsart der menschen das war der
kern der aufklärung die veränderung der
denkungsart der menschen die die
richtung kopf wechseln sozusagen kant
klima kehrtwende es geht um potenziale
herausforderungen neue technologien das
wort verzicht fehlt veränderung positiv
besetzt ein dickes buch viele argumente
werden sie gehört von einer neuen
regierung ein dickes buch das allerdings
auch dekorativ im regal verschwinden
könnte
wenn es nach den autoren geht soll es
das ganz sicher nicht volker angriffs
ist der chef unserer umwelt redaktion
volker was bis da los die deutsche
industrie und ihre beratergremien
spielen frei des for future am
donnerstag ja ich war nicht wirklich
überrascht das deutete sich schon eine
ganze weile an wie heißt es so schön der
krug geht so lange zum brunnen bis er
bricht offenbar ist er gebrochen und das
heißt die alten märkte schaffen keine
profite mehr bei die unternehmen wollen
in den neuen märkten bei den
erneuerbaren energien dabei sein da
gibt's das stichwort wasserstoff
wasserstoff brauchen wir unbedingt in
einer neuen energiewelt weil es ein
universell einsetzbarer energieträger
ist und die welt macht das schon japan
ist bei korea ist dabei die amerikaner
sind dabei wir müssen mal langsam anfang
um den anschluss nicht zu verpassen das
treibt die wirtschaft an also bisher hat
die wirtschaft klimapolitik vor allen
dingen dann gewollt wenn es zuschüsse
dafür gab
staatsknete und ansonsten waren die
hauptsächlich daran interessiert ihre
alten anlagen weiter zu benutzen denn
das brachte die profite diese rechnung
geht jetzt nicht mehr aufgeht nicht mehr
so auf natürlich wird es auch weiter
jetzt fördermittel geben müssen um in
diese neue energiewelt einzusteigen es
ist ja wirklich dramatisch was nötig ist
wir brauchen bis 2030 mindestens die
verdoppelung wenn dich die
verdreifachung des angebotes an
erneuerbaren energien
da frage ich mich ehrlich gesagt wo
sollen die ganzen windparks eigentlich
noch stehen das wird eine
herkulesaufgabe und ein windpark bis er
fertig ist sechs jahre planungs und
genehmigungszeiten das ist normal das
muss runter auf sechs monate da bin ich
sehr gespannt wie die neue regierung das
hinkriegen möchten nun gab es eine menge
seitenhiebe jetzt heute auf die politik
und das die hat ja auch so ihre zwänge
also im grunde will jeder klimaschutz
irgendwie machen aber wenn es dann um
windrad in der nähe oder wenn es um eine
hochspannungsleitung für den transfer
von windenergie von nord nach süd dann
bayern am liebsten jeden meter davon
tief unter der erde verbuddeln und wird
sonst keine landtagswahlen machen dieser
politische morast der sich um dieses
thema immer entwickelt hat den kann die
industrie auch nicht weg wenn die
industrie nicht aber das darum geht es
ja gerade die neue regierung die muss
halt diese rahmenbedingungen schaffen
damit es voran kommt ich frage mich
allerdings auch wie will man mit
bürgerinitiativen umgehende garantiert
aus dem boden sprießen werden um zu
verhindern dass das neue windrad in
sichtweite des eigenen garten steht das
ist ganz klar das wird so kommen wie man
sich da verhält ob es richtung
enteignung dann laufen wird keine ahnung
das wird sich dann einfach noch zeigen
müssen und ganz wichtig und das ist
nicht auch wirklich neu aber heute
deutlich rausgekommen wir brauchen mehr
internationale kooperation auch gerade
beim thema wasserstoff deutschland wird
es nicht schaffen den sogenannten grünen
wasserstoff der mithilfe der
erneuerbaren energien hergestellt wird
völlig alleine herzen steine wollen wir
partner und die müssen gefunden werden
das ist eine neue aufgabe die auch von
der neuen bundesregierung dringend
angegangen werden muss vielleicht kommt
daher jetzt plötzlich was zusammen dass
die industrie umdenkt und neue
forderungen stellt und gleichzeitig
bewegt es sich auf eine neue regierung
dazu die so was ja auch versprochen hat
ihrem wahlprogramm ich fürchte da gibt
es keine andere möglichkeit wenn man die
ziele wirklich erreichen möchte dann
muss es genauso sein wohlgemerkt ja
etwas teufelchen ist hörnchen die
umsetzung wir haben darüber gesprochen
das ist das problem da ist noch ganz
viel zu tun ja und das leitet jetzt
perfekt über zu den nachrichten der
gudula beginnt mit den verhandlungen
hinter streng verschlossenen türen wo
solche themen verhandelt werden
inzwischen zwischen rot gelb und grün
unterhändler von spd grünen und fdp
haben erneut im kleinen kreis an einem
gemeinsamen beschlusspapier der
sondierungsgespräche gearbeitet
dieses soll grundlage für die gespräche
morgen ab 9 uhr sein wenn in größerer
runde von 26 sondieren über die
entscheidung für die aufnahme von
koalitionsverhandlungen beraten wird
sollte die zwischenbilanz akzeptiert
werden müssen noch führende
parteigremien zustimmen
wegen der pannen bei der wahl zum
berliner abgeordnetenhaus hat die
landeswahlleitung einspruch beim
berliner verfassungsgerichtshof
angekündigt in zwei wahlkreisen habe es
rechtsverstöße gegeben zugleich deutet
sich in berlin auf landesebene eine
fortsetzung des rot grün roten
regierungsbündnisses an
spd-landeschefin giffey kündigte eine
weitere sondierungsrunden mit grünen und
linken dabei warnte sie auch ein
einfaches weiter so könne es nicht geben
weltweit hungern wieder mehr menschen
das ziel der vereinten nationen den
hunger bis zum jahr 2030 zu besiegen
rückt in immer weitere ferne das zeigt
der aktuelle welthunger index den das
welternährungsprogramm und in berlin die
präsidentin der welthungerhilfe
thieme vorgestellt haben demnach sind es
kriege die folgen des klimawandels und
die corona park die die lage
verschlechtern so waren es im
vergangenen jahr weltweit etwa 811
millionen menschen die hungerten nach
690 millionen im jahr zuvor
aus nigeria wird der tod des anführers
der terror miliz islamischer staat in
westafrika gemeldet bestätigt von einem
sprecher der nigerianischen armee der
mann soll eine miliz angeführt haben die
sich von der terror gruppe boko haram
abgespalten hatte die kämpfe der
verfeindeten extremisten untereinander
und mit der armee haben in den letzten
jahren zehntausende menschen das leben
gekostet
in libanons hauptstadt beirut ist es bei
protesten gegen die schleppende
aufarbeitung
der explosionskatastrophe vom letzten
jahr zu schweren unruhen gekommen dabei
wurden heute sechs menschen getötet und
mindestens 30 verletzt schiitische
gruppen hatten für die absetzung des
zuständigen richters demonstriert als
schüsse und explosionen zu hören waren
schickte die armee panzer die gefechte
erinnern beobachter an den bürgerkrieg
im libanon bei der explosion falsch
gelagerten ammoniumnitrat waren mehr als
190 menschen getötet und für 6000
verletzt worden
in der klimadebatte versuchen immer mehr
interessierte länder die kernenergie
wieder ins spiel zu bringen weil sie
fast ohne treibhausgase auskommt
frankreich setzt massiv darauf eu
staaten wie tschechien die slowakei
ungarn und bulgarien auch das ist
natürlich hoch umstritten russland
verbindet die probleme alter fossile
brennstoffe nun innovativ mit den
gefahren der kernenergie um im tausenden
arktischen meer in regionen wie um pewag
öl gas und andere bodenschätze zu
fördern braucht man erstmal energie dort
draußen im nirgendwo und da setzt
russland auf schwimmende kraftwerke vor
gut zehn jahren haben wir für eine zdf
doku auf einer werft in st petersburg
gefilmt wo so ein akw schiff die riesige
akademik lomonossow
zusammen gespeist wurde das ist
schwerindustrie vom gröbsten der dreh
war am 12 märz 2011 dem tag an dem in
japan das akw von fukushima in die luft
flog frontaler können probleme nicht
aufeinander prallen mittlerweile ist
diese akademik lomonossow im einsatz und
unser moskau-korrespondent bekam
tatsächlich eine drehgenehmigung
es ist eine reise ans ende der welt von
moskau und nach brig zwölf flugstunden
zeitunterschied neun stunden
in einer 40 jahre alten antonow maschine
fliegen wir weiter jk im winter kann es
hier bis zu minus 40 grad kalt werden
der weg ist die nördlichste stadt
russlands vor der küste der
ostsibirischen see ist sie nicht zu
übersehen die akademik lomonossow das
erste schwimmende atomkraftwerk der welt
144 meter lang 30 meter breit von
murmansk ihr her geschleppt versorgt ist
die region seit letztem jahr mit strom
und wärme
wir sind die er ist nur deshalb sind wir
darauf stolz
der größte vorteil ist die mobilität man
kann dieses kraftwerk irgendwo in einer
abgelegenen werfen bauen und dann auf
dem seeweg in dem benötigten ort bringen
unzählige treppen und gänge laufen wie
hoch und runter da kommen am tag schnell
ein paar kilometer zusammen erzählen uns
die arbeiter das kraftwerk ist wie eine
kleinstadt
es gibt eine sporthalle ein
fitnessstudio und einen pool märz 200
menschen arbeiten hier betrieben wird
das akw von zwei mini reaktoren die in
ähnlicher form auch auf eisbrechern im
einsatz sind sie treiben turbinen und
generatoren an 100.000 menschen können
so mit energie versorgt werden
umweltschützer sehen das projekt
kritisch bezeichnen das akw auch als
schwimmendes tschernobyl
das hauptrisiko dieser konstruktion ist
dass es keinen letzt fahrendes schiff
das heißt es hat keinen schiffs mit und
das schiff könnte durch eisschollen
zerdrückt werden die akademik lomonossow
ist das prestige projekte russischen
energieversorgung und peer weg ist ein
strategisch wichtiger ort es geht um den
kampf um die russische vormachtstellung
in der arktis
tschukotka ist dünn besiedelt aber reich
an bodenschätzen
wir fahren zu einer golden vier
autostunden schotter und eispiste
auch sie bekommen ihren strom vom
schwimmenden akw alleine hier wurden im
letzten jahr vier tonnen gold gefördert
es ist sehr wenig erkundet in der arktis
es geht vor allem um bodenschätze für
die interessiert man sich sehr
auch deshalb ist die schiffspassage
durch die arktis für russland von großer
bedeutung milliarden werden investiert
in die veraltete infrastruktur in
energie und transport um den nördlichen
seeweg als globale handelsroute zu
etablieren soll auch der hafen in
perfekt um das drei bis vierfache
wachsen
neue große eis brechen die die
schifffahrt in unseren arktischen
gewässern das ganze jahr gewährleisten
der vorteil für die weltwirtschaft am
seeweg durch die arktis ist dass es
keine piraten
für die russische arktis offensive
sollen kraftwerke wie das in perfekt die
energieversorgung sichern und noch mehr
vier weitere schwimmende atomkraftwerke
sind bereits in planung
aus norwegen kamen gestern abend die
ersten meldungen über ein verbrechen von
geradezu bizarrer grausamkeit da zog
offenbar ein mit pfeil und bogen
bewaffneter mann durch das städtchen
kongsberg südwestlich von oslo tötete
fünf menschen und verletzte drei weitere
schwer hannah hebestreit ist für uns in
kongsberg hannah wie konnte ein mann mit
so beschränkter bewaffnung derart
tödlich zu schlagen
das ist natürlich die ganz große frage
die beamten waren sehr schnell hier
wenige minuten nach der alarmierung aber
hier mitten in der innenstadt von spec
wurden sie dann selbst angegriffen die
männer mussten sich zurückziehen und
ausrüstung zum eigenschutz anlegen und
in der zeit ist der verdächtige
verschwunden und hat dann angefangen die
leute zu beschießen oder anderweitig
anzugreifen
bis die beamten schließlich stellen
konnte hat er diese fünf menschen
umgebracht drei weitere noch verletzt
die polizei muss sie sicherlich einige
fragen stellen lassen was da im detail
vielleicht noch schief gelaufen ist die
rede ist jetzt von einem terroristisch
islamistisch begründeten tatmotiv wie
belastbar sind solche meldungen
ja das ist die heikle frage heute mittag
haben die haben die norwegischen
ermittler gesagt sie sieht diese gehen
von einem terrorverdacht aus davon sind
sich inzwischen nicht mehr ganz so
überzeugt sie haben jetzt auch mediziner
zugezogen sind sich nicht ganz sicher ob
der mann der in der vergangenheit immer
wieder kontakt mit norwegens
gesundheitssystem gehabt hatte was ich
auch immer hinter dieser frage verbirgt
ob der mann vielleicht doch tatsächlich
krank ist das wird in den nächsten tagen
ermittelt werden müssen sicher ist vor
vier jahren hat er ein recht gutes video
gepostet in dem verlauf er sich dann zum
islam bekannt hat was aber am ende damit
ausgesagt werden soll das ist jetzt
aufgabe der ermittler in den nächsten
tagen der licht in dieses im wahrsten
sinne des wortes dunkel zu bringen wir
können das abwarten dankeschön henne und
hier kommen noch einmal nachrichten
bundeskanzlerin merkel hat europa zu
einigkeit aufgerufen und vor
fliehkräften in der eu gewarnt auch im
umgang mit china müsse europa mit einer
stimme sprechen erklärte sie in spanien
wo sie mit dem renommierten preis karl
der fünfte ausgezeichnet wurde für ihre
verdienste um europa könig felipe
würdigte merkel als persönlichkeit die
ihrer zeit stets voraus gewesen sei in
ihrer dankesrede warnte merkel davor
nationale interesse über den nutzen des
gemeinsamen europäischen projekts zu
stellen
die deutsche wirtschaft leidet weiterhin
unter den folgen der korona pandemie so
die analyse führender
wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute die ihre
konjunkturprognose für dieses jahr
deutlich nach unten korrigieren sina
mainitz trotz lieferengpässen und hoher
inflation sehen sie aber auch positive
signale
ja denn geht es nach den
wirtschaftsforschern sollte sich die
lage kommendes jahr deutlich entspannen
fürs laufende jahr waren sie aber eben
zu optimistisch mit ihrer prognose und
deshalb kamen im heutigen
herbstgutachten auch nach unten
korrigierte zahlen heraus so wächst die
wirtschaft dieses jahr nicht mehr um 3,7
prozent sondern nur noch um 2,4 für
kommendes jahr gehen die forscher davon
aus dass die wirtschaft gerade im
zweiten halbjahr deutlich anziehen wird
und prognostizieren ein wachstum von 4,8
prozent
allerdings gibt es einige faktoren die
diesen rasanten anstieg ausbremsen
könnten als gründe werden weiterhin die
lieferengpässe der fachkräftemangel die
lockdown folgen und die inflation
genannt die steigenden preise bereiten
vielen sorge im september lag die
inflationsrate bei 4,1
nachholeffekte und hohe energiepreise
sind die gründe dafür aber offenbar
scheint die spitze des eisbergs nun für
die wirtschaftsforscher erreicht zu sein
kommendes jahr wird eine preissteigerung
von zweieinhalb prozent erwartet und da
atmen auch die anleger auf der dax
erreicht heute abend den höchsten stand
seit zwei wochen am ende schließt er mit
15.400 63 punkten
gute firmenbilanzen gepaart mit dieser
hoffnung dass die deutsche wirtschaft
die pandemie kommendes jahr endlich
hinter sich lassen könnte sorgen für
diese gute laune am börsenparkett stehen
dank wien nach frankfurt gerne beim
tennis turnier im kalifornischen indian
wells ist alexander zverev ins
viertelfinale eingezogen souverän
besiegte die deutsche nummer eins den
franzosen mowis nächster gegner ist der
amerikaner taylor fritz nach dem aus von
us-open-sieger
medwedew zählt zu den titel favoriten in
indian wells die historische dürre im
westen der usa hat zu einem weiteren
großbrand geführt in der nähe des
kalifornischen küstenort santa barbara
stehen inzwischen mehr als 62
quadratkilometer in flammen eine
hauptverkehrsader entlang der küste
musste gesperrt werden etwa 100 gebäude
sind von den feuern bedroht experten
führen die dürre auf den klimawandel
zurück waldbrände habe es immer gegeben
aber jetzt würden sie häufiger und
größer
der zauberhafte film den nadia nasser
uns vorstellt dreht sich um generationen
und um bodenständigkeit bodenständigkeit
von der sorte die einen nicht fesselt
sondern losfliegen und zurückkehren
lässt zu magischen orten einem bergsee
einem gasthaus die magie von berg sehen
kennt jeder gasthäuser haben die aber
auch familienbetriebe meistens wo man in
den offenen armen der wirtsleute in der
atmosphäre der stube der fühlbaren
tradition spürt da haben generationen
ihrer haltung und ihr können
weitergegeben da braucht es dann keine
sterne im restaurantführer gibt es
trotzdem dann manchmal im café am
walchensee aber nicht dort kam das glück
dazu dass die vierte generation der
wirtsfamilie eine begnadete
filmemacherin hervorbrachte und starke
frauen den mut und das vertrauen hatten
bei deren großen projekt mitzumachen
ich muss die ganze geschichte erzählen
alles bis heute
seit 90 jahren steht das café an
meiner großmutter eine ganz stolz
erscheinung hat ihren wirten da seien
auch sehr genossen in den sattel zu
machen vier frauen leben die
unterschiedlicher nicht sein könnten und
doch so viel verbindet eine
außergewöhnliche familiengeschichte
filmemacherin gianna die wanderers ist
die jüngste der vier frauen ein kind der
hippie-zeit aufgewachsen zwischen san
francisco walchensee und im haaren von
rainer langhans
[Musik]
ich mache ja ein fehler ich mache einen
film
ja
ein film über uns frauen und die
familiengeschichte
es ist eine jahrhundert erzählung auf
jeden fall muss es geht um den kreislauf
des lebens wo man eben auch meine
großmutter als ganz junge frau sieht um
diesen alterungsprozess bis bis zu ihrem
fast 100 fünften lebensjahr das wird die
vergänglichkeit wird am auch so bewusst
jedes frauenleben ein spiegel der
gesellschaft
da sind die bodenständige oma der
filmemacherin die pflichtbewusst im
familiencafé dienst tut und dann deren
freiheitsliebende töchter anna und
frauke die es ende der 60er jahre in die
usa und nach mexiko zieht
mit trachten hackbrett und gitarre um
dort als jodelnde hippie bayerinnen
furore zu machen
die suche im leben
das war von anfang an bei uns thema auch
mit meiner schwester damals und wie wir
uns in die welt bewegt habe und
eigentlich die welt umarmen wollen über
ihre schwester frau kennt anna während
des sogenannten sommers der liebe den
kommunarden rainer langhans kennen
die 25 wochen nackt in einer höhle
gelebt
wahrscheinlich in etwa
nach einem schicksalsschlag geht anna in
die usa bekommt dort mit dem amerikaner
jason wanderers ihre tochter gianna aber
immer wieder zieht es sie zurück in die
heimat an den walchensee
trostspender und ruhepol für alle frauen
der familie bis heute
der weichen sie ist dieser stille zeuge
der stumme zeugen der alles beobachtet
die menschlichen dramen die da passieren
weichen sie forever ist ein bewegendes
zeitdokument über den wandel der
gesellschaft in einem jahrhundert über
sinnsuche und neubeginn am beispiel
einer familie absolut sehenswert
und dann war da noch corona bis zu 80
prozent sind vollständig geimpft hieß es
zuletzt in einem bericht und trotzdem
steigt der druck auf ungeimpfte stärker
als die infektionszahlen zurzeit keine
lohnfortzahlung mehr keine kostenlosen
corona tests immer öfter zweig was soll
das muss das sein maybrit illner und
ihre gäste
diskutieren über geimpft fragezeichen
haben wir die nerven um mehr freiheit zu
wahren
und um 0.30 meldet sich christopher
wehrmann mit unserem heute-journal
update
die größere kamera
[Musik]
guten abend das östliche mittelmeer ist
noch sehr warm das hat
wassertemperaturen von 25 bis 27 grad da
hat sich ein tief entwickelt und das
gibt schon den ganzen tag über kräftige
gewitter dort und auch in den nächsten
tagen wird es richtung griechenland
weiter kräftig regnen mit uns hat das
nichts zu tun wir können uns auf das
hoch philine einstellen dass uns am
wochenende sonnenschein bringt dieses
hoch philine zeichnet sich schon morgen
ab hier über schottland vorher aber muss
noch die kaltfront von tief gerald durch
und diese kaltfront zieht weiter bis in
die mitte deutschlands und da löst sie
sich im wesentlichen auf die kaltfront
kommt schon heute nacht an in
norddeutschland da wehte wind stürmisch
aus westlichen richtungen sonst ist es
meist wolkig und südlich der donau auch
klar da bildet sich dann eben dort
sinken die temperaturen auf plus 2 bis
minus 1 grad es droht also bodenfrost
zwischen dem vogtland und der eifel sind
es 45 grad weiter im norden liegen die
nachtwerte bei 12 bis 7 grad morgen über
tag liegen die werte damals bei 14 grad
etwas kühler ist es in den
mittelgebirgen wärmen dagegen am neckar
oder am oberrhein mit 17 grad die kann
von der nacht zieht morgen vormittag
schon weiter nach süden erreicht berlin
den harz und auch das sauerland dahinter
lockern die wolken schon wieder auf und
der wind dreht von süd west auf nordwest
in süddeutschland gibt nach nebel viel
sonne das ändert sich auch am nachmittag
nicht die kaltfront löst sich auf der
samstag mit ruhig sonntag am montag
könnte es dann im äußersten norden etwas
regnen und es wird wärmer guten abend